[موسيقى]
لنحافظ على لايكاتنا البدنيه برمضان يحسن
لنا استخدام انتقاء الوقت المناسب طبعا
بده يكون في شويه طاقه بجسمنا وبده يكون
الرياضه مناسبه
للمستوى الطاقه والتوقيت في اليوم برمضان
اذا سالنا عن افضل الاوقات ممارسه الرياضه
في رمضان تكون بالنسبه اليه بعد ساعتين
ثلاث ساعات ما بعد الافطار كون اخذنا
الطاقه المناسبه والسوائل بجسمنا صارت
صارت موجوده هذا الوقت
بيعطينا مجال نمارس تقريبا كل انواع
الرياضات التي تنقسم ما بين قد يكون رفع
اثقال او ممارسه
ركض او كره قدم قد يكون ممارسه فقط دراجه
هوائيه او حتى ما يسمى بالبوش ابس
اذا بدنا نعمل في اوقات اخرى ممكن ممارسه
فيها الرياضه مثل ما قبل الافطار مباشره
نصف ساعه لمكسيما ساعه ولكن هذه بدنا
ننتبه انه احنا بكون تقريبا ما في سوائل
فما نجعل عضلنا وجسمنا بده يكون بس فقط
ممارسات خفيفه لا تصلح حدود مثلا ممارسه
الرفع الاوزان او ممارسه مثلا لعبه القدم
[موسيقى]
مليء بعده احداث عن عبادات ان عمل ونوم
وعائله ورياضه فنحاول من البدايه نختار
الوقت المناسب لرياضتنا نتاكد انه اول كم
يوم برمضان غير عن بعدين فاول كم يوم
برمضان رياضتنا لازم تكون بمستوى قليل جدا
جدا وبعدين شوي شوي خلال رمضان بس يتعدى
جسمنا على الوضع ممكن المزيد من النشاطات
الرياضيه نتاكد دائما انه في سوائل كميه
سائل جيده باسمنا بالذات ما بين طبعا
الفطور والسحور ونتاكد انه اختيار
الرياضات لن يكون
اعنف مما احنا متعودين عليه نحن نحافظ على
اللياقه ولا نبني عضل او منافس لرمضان
[موسيقى]